it's just pork skin fried you know what
a gift
[Music]
bring on the snacks
oh the classic pretzel and Gregg's what
is this it smells a much greasy er than
the pretzel I know what this tastes like
was it a sausage roll or that great
there we go oh wow
come on States bring on the sausage roll
oh oh
toxic waste I've never seen this before
in my life
this is liquors of all sorts it has a
weird like it's good and it's like no no
no I mean it becomes good again this is
exciting
okay all right you got to try one you
gotta try one here you go everybody
there you go I'm gonna keep this one for
me I'm gonna go and believe it or not
I'm gonna go with the toxic waste well
down America you did it again
Oh twiglets I've never seen either of
these so you'd be pretty right
[Music]
they're pretty they're pretty
interesting actually they kind of have a
burnt taste Tim and do draw I should can
I change my answer I'm gonna change my
answer sorry America
I think it's twiglets I I just I have to
be honest you know I just kept wanting
more twiglets Oh mr. port these crispy
strips the lighter porky snack they both
look terrifying it's just pork skin
fried you know what a gift thank you oh
I can't oh my god people eat this so you
have to get drunk do you make sense
I can't I can't the smell is enough yeah
I mean this is it's a sugary meaty snack
what's not like so Jack Daniels versus
Johnnie Walker red label good morning
everybody
it's nice they're both good I'm gonna
have to go with the the Johnny Walker no
no God no no oh well done you play you
did it again
Cheers [ __ ] shame shame on you
[Music]